today's topic
[Music]
i've sent or received nudes
three
[Laughter]
that's exactly the word that was in my
head in my head i'm like
cause you're gonna get my textbook
because she said do i have to answer
this yeah
if one day i want to get a certain job
or go into
a political office i just don't ever
want to have somebody to hold that
against me even when people send me
nudes i'm like i didn't
necessarily need that like when they're
just you know
are we saying nudes nudes
are saying news n-e-w-s
i'm so sorry i don't send nudes because
i just do things on social media i want
to pursue acting
i feel like my body is a temple you
gotta pay to see it if at least
that's a zoomer let's zoomer if you
don't know what a zoomer is it's
generation agent z acting like a boomer
consumer i like it she's like i have
self-respect i want to have a career so
i wouldn't post nudes
but if you pay no i wouldn't post that
on the internet i want to do that you
know i got things to do
and i want more people to have it would
you want money for it
maybe
you love that question
[Applause]
i hope so the funny thing is you can't
see his face under the mask
revenge porn is very real and i think
most women or women adjacent people
have received um unsolicited
picks as like a bisexual person and kind
of just being in like
a world that's hyper sexualized already
and it sucks because that's kind of like
the age of social media and like lgbtq
youth is that
pretty much like they have to seek
validation online that's like really
like the way to do it
i agree exactly with what makai said i
mean it is like the form of validation
now like sending nudes is love
but this makes me just want to yeah this
makes me just want to jump over it
because i feel like i'm in the wrong
area you know we're going to go here if
guys guys guys this is not whether
you're not you agree or disagree with
newts the question was
have you sent them how can you say yes i
have and then be like well based off
your opinion i feel like i should
what am i crazy
yes what
no z
[Music]
no like they should respect your values
if you don't want to send
nudes and if they if not like it's
pretty clear to me that they're just
using me for my body
nudes has a lot to do with appearance
and putting a lot of value on how you
appear
can just just sometimes be damaging to
piggyback off that it's really important
too like when you're growing up no
matter like your body type or how you
look
everyone has like beauty in them and
that's exactly it
that's exactly what it is have you sent
news
yes but you shouldn't send new this
is the man that's not that's not yo
but we've all done a mistake yeah that's
not the question that's not the question
have you you know what i also appreciate
about this
this is very representative they got a
muslim girl a gay dude
bisexual dude asian
some whites in the back white trash so
it's important to love your body and
love like how you look because like girl
that's your body like flaunt what you
got boo
that validation needs to come from
within not from other people because
like i know i'm sexy i don't know
i'm sexy so um period poo
is that going in skinny jeans
are out of style
three two one go
yeah i don't know it was just the era of
the time it was like rock was like
you know pop rock lots of skinny jeans
and then turn into like ripped jeans i
think pants are getting bigger i don't
know if it's because like
maybe we're shifting more towards like
androgyny i just i'm over here
because i think that's skinny jeans i
don't like them and i would wear them
because i also have like chicken legs so
like that's not happening for me they're
out of styler in style
girl girl you need to listen girl stay
focused
yes okay gen z everyone says you guys
can't focus
you're not helping they are in style yes
can you just oh no they're out of style
[Applause]
this girl this girl and then the guy's
gonna be like oh you know what i'm gonna
scoop over there
because uh because i'm sexy
you know the amount of group thing going
on right now it's like crazy i recently
bought my like first pair of like bag
your jeans kind of like
what he's wearing and i was like blown
away honestly like there's so much space
you don't have to worry about like
bunching up and stuff like yeah i don't
know why
we ever stuck with skinny jeans to begin
with i think
the whole skinny jeans side part thing
is generational politics that are trying
to like
distract us from what we actually
disagree about like nobody
actually cares about the skinny jeans
and middle parts like millennials
they trying to distract you you don't
need no help to get distracted
you can't answer you can't understand a
simple question girl no
is this really a talking point yeah yeah
they took all the points of the gen z
remember what they did with black you
know how they did i'm not on social
media after are they really talking
about skinny jeans
do we really like chicken watermelon is
kanye west invited to the to the cookout
remember how they did us dirty it's the
same
same thing but with them okay so it's
not a talking point how are you
surprised
i get my news from youtube
three two one go
and then the asian girl's gonna be like
news or nudes
yoga i get from youtube what are you
talking about
[Laughter]
i just somewhat disagree because i try
not to just you know stay on youtube
because it can
be a lot of disinformation but i also
feel like you know i follow a lot of
political youtubers and i feel like
their perspectives are different than
what's on the mainstream because like
three corporations own all of the media
social news twitter 100
easily but like if it's like some
political stuff i have like
subscriptions to like
new york times even fox and stuff just
so that i get perspective from everyone
and i tend to go ahead and like focus
more on like the journalism
stuff and youtube is like the headlines
but i don't click the video and like
deliberately watch it until i've known
the facts the ability of twitter to get
you know opinions out there from people
who aren't political pundits
um is really valuable and you know when
when big things happen
twitter usually hears about it first i
feel like it kind of just comes down to
like a media literacy thing and it's
something that like
our generation and further generations
are gonna have to face we haven't been
in this era where there's like which
what sarah was saying about like the
democratized way of social media where
like everyone can say information
we're like in this new era where we
pretty much have to learn how to
decipher
which is valuable and valid information
what's not and like as
social media continues to grow i feel
like it's just gonna keep becoming more
literate
and i feel like we should be taught this
in schools we're a whole new era like we
grew up with like tablets and laptops
whereas in like previous generations
didn't
which allows us obviously to have more
diverse opinions but i think that should
be taught in school as well
do your guys parents ever just call you
and be like did you know this happened
you're like yeah it happened like five
hours ago and you were like did you just
find out now
it's usually fake news with my mom
usually fake news
i will agree with her on that parents
are super susceptible to fake
articles you know what people in general
people constantly send us like onion
articles but could you believe
that a man ran into a tent showed his uh
penis which was attached to an
elephant's head and then ran out and
said i as well
i don't know it's like bro did you read
the source did you read any of the
articles did you look at the
no so people are just very susceptible
to
not doing any form or like even i'm not
saying you got to know everything but
people won't even do a simple google
search to see like are there any other
news sources that cover this
you know i mean you have to have this
conversation all the time then sometimes
you read a headline for me i'm like have
you checked with other sources
yeah always well that that's the first
thing that we cannot go
because yeah you can't go out there and
pray and spread
you know [ __ ] we're gonna get called on
yeah she gets you
from facebook literally she calls me
she's like did you hear about this like
mom
yeah like my mom when she was on
instagram she was like
she was seeing the wrong stuff and then
she was like you know the vaccine
those microchips and i was like mom i
think it's also important to think about
like
why people believe that like yeah it's
like stupid and it's funny to make fun
of but like
people are afraid of like you know
really rich people
who are going to be like controlling a
lot of stuff without
you know democratic elections and
without any
accountability and it makes sense that
people would feel
like you know i don't really know if i
can trust
the government my parents and i
agree on political and social issues
three two one go
my job girl's out here sending nudes you
better go all the way
it's not just she's sending nudes is
that she's like
feels weird about it so you already know
yeah
the pressure yeah the haram
my parents like raised me again on the
whole thing of like look at every single
side
and i guess it didn't go necessarily
their way but at the same time like
sometimes it ends up being a wreck but
like whenever it's a wreck we come back
and we're like i see your point
but here's what i think and here's why
loaded with facts not just like oh i
think this because this and this and
this x and x and said
no it's because it's a percentage this
is a statistic that i'm pointing out
honestly i used to try and like show
them a different perspective and like
have an open conversation but like i'm
kind of at the point now where it's like
you know what let's just not talk about
it
it's probably for the best you know my
parents always say to me like you
pay attention to politics more than we
do and we like learn from you and
sometimes we get into little arguments
that can be a good like way to sort of
inform each other because obviously they
have more experience like
historically like what went on but they
can also say like
yeah i don't understand you know this
specific issue
can you you know get me up to speed i
would like to have a disclaimer for my
mom and dad what's coming out of my
mouth is coming out through love
also if they're watching this please
stop watching this my parents are very
close-minded and conservative and there
have been fights as in daniel's family i
feel like in my household my opinion is
not valid
and it will never be valid as long as i
live
i have felt depressed three
two one go
so i'm about to have a really vulnerable
moment with y'all
so my whole life i have been so bullied
and words hurt so much
and six months ago i almost took my life
because of like
like words um they have this effect on
you
and sometimes you can't talk to people
about it
and my friend's mom posted
if you needed to talk to someone to call
this number and i talked to them
and i spoke to them on the phone for two
hours by myself at nighttime
and if it wasn't for her just doing that
i feel like i wouldn't have been here
today
can i give you a hug yeah it's okay
give him that gen z group hug no because
every time
everybody's like no not going there
i'm not kobe my mom the chips
can't do that even when he said like all
my life i was like oh my life ah man
let me listen for this shot my dick get
bigger so i can [ __ ] the word [ __ ] i'm
sorry i wanted to gain drake yeah
remember
that looks like different i'm glad that
uh he's overcome that
yeah i got that i think mental health
issues are stored through the roof and
uh
if you want something to invest in
anybody who does these online therapy
sessions or anything like that a company
definitely a good idea because it's
going to become a bigger issue not not
no scam just a real thing but the thing
that happened as well
is that him having conservative
parents like he said having super
conservative parents sometimes
and him being flamboyant
you don't feel like you can't talk to
your parents like that you don't feel
like you're happy
you sometimes you can feel like you can
be stuck even your siblings sometimes
you can't talk to them me i was
fortunate i could talk to my
my sister anytime i wanted you tell your
parents that you're gay
do you know the way you were setting up
this whole thing that's what they were
thinking i don't give a [ __ ]
why you gotta say it you know
words are very important you trash ass
human beings anyways
hello yeah i can understand where he's
from where he's going coming coming from
i am optimistic about the future
three two one
[Music]
go
personally it's in my nature to not be
optimistic because i think a lot of
people in our generation are very
nihilistic i try not to like
view it like that because it's very like
deterministic
like well the world's going to hell like
we can't do anything
and if you believe that then like you're
not
fighting for like a better world and
you're not fighting for change
i'm very much with sarah on the point
where our generation is very cynical
very nihilistic we
like to just like assume that things
can't be fixed to be honest with you
that's every generation
the amount of people i see gizelle
always online well the end of the world
is coming yeah end times like your
parents do this
everyone doesn't it's not every
generation the 70s the hippie generation
they were very hopeful for the world man
all
we are saying it's give pizza it'll pass
me a little piece of that bud
that that's that's what it was maybe
during the 70s yeah but after that but
it all went into shits 90s on a word
oh once the internet came along the 70s
gone was done it was done
like yeah yo yeah seth so that's not
really a jinzy thing but yeah
because in the past they just never were
i don't know i think i'm very optimistic
for the future because i believe
as we become more educated and we have
more resources to certain things and
information
we can do great things but we just have
to believe that we can or else it won't
happen
now i'm feeling sad about saying someone
disagree i just was thinking about this
in like the climate perspective and like
social media how it's been used so
negatively
um when i think about those two major
things
i can't see it stopping anywhere it's a
little unimaginable it's like
yeah no like i want to be positive of
course and i want the change to happen
but like
like where does it start i try to be
positive and i try to
i always say like if there's something
you don't like we can work on it and fix
it and i think that this generation in
particular is really good at that like
gen z is crazy like we
get things done the impact we've had
with like tick tock even
like yeah we we've changed a lot of
things
you know what maybe i'm just unaware
maybe but i don't know what they change
what they talk
yeah maybe they think they've changed
minds and educated people but like
youtube did the same thing for folks
twitter's on the same like i don't know
oh what change you brought about with
ticktop are you sure
i think that gen z gets a bit of a bad
rap
because of the fact that you know my
generation the millennials
right we had we we went the transition
from
no internet to having internet and so
now we're constantly seeing the younger
generation online every day doing tick
tocks and other stuff we find cringy
and so there's such an influx of
contact with younger people all the time
that their cringe seems
far more than it actually is in terms of
like
it being present but if you were
thinking about it our parents generation
looked at us the same way
and their parents generation looked at
them the same way so it's just a
repeating cycle that's why i don't look
at gen z and be like what the
it's just a different generation that's
it i know some people like gen z's lost
they got purple hair they [ __ ] they're
inclusive it's like who cares
you know it's like i don't rag on them i
don't even think it's that cringy
personally from what i've seen it's just
like that's their thing you know
but it's just a it's just a natural path
of what we're doing they're just more
inclusive than what we were but we don't
we said they tell
our parents at the tone before that it's
just the
the progression of our generation yeah
it's just the path that it
i'm not surprised by it i could cringe
about it but i'm not surprised by it
yeah some things are weird but i'm like
yeah you know i was a little weirder
when i was a kid so
yeah whatever i think it's easy to dunk
on gen z because they're such easy but
it's just like
every every younger generation is
an easy target watch the other
generations gonna come after that
yeah yeah so that's it you know they got
their own set of problems the way we had
our own set of problems
you know my set of problems involved
like real violence my parents generation
another set of even more real violence
in this generation
mental health and look now as i'm older
mental health is becoming more of an
issue but
younger days like nobody ever talked
about it not saying it wasn't present
but it just wasn't the focal point of
our struggle
violence however that was a different
story and i think with these kids like
you know they're growing up with
different issues and different problems
and they're tackling it in a different
way and even if i don't approve or love
any of it
but i'll go on here be like well gen z
is trash
some people get too caught up in that
but those are my thoughts what do you
think
fine all right well
in that case leave your comments below
tell us what you guys think about gen z
in this whole discussion
personally i thought the cast members
were cool they were different had some
opinions they were well thought out i
was actually kind of pleasantly
surprised
about how well informed that they stay
because compared to our generation
there seemed to be way more plugged in
than we were but i think that's because
they're more socially adept and
there's more options for them so you're
taking advantage
[Music]
is
that keeps you